I'm going to show you go shoot 3 damage
that again first one is whether you
already know how to do so let's have a
look at something like this again this
is something that end extension one
context you get a clue for let you guys
know the inner wall of sine squared X
couldn't do this thing okay what
identities can I use that will help me
yeah I'm close to it yeah fantastic so
you can write this off on the side if
you want just to help you work out what
on earth is going on cos 2x has cos
squared and science credit which of
course means you can interchange between
there soon as you want so if i write cos
square x minus sine squared X over here
I want the form that only has sinus meds
in it right so I'm going to replace this
guy with one minus sine squared so I'm
going to get 1 minus 2 sine squared over
here and you can see here just by a
simple rear a true that what I'm going
to get over here is the integral are
half time what caused 1 minus cost of it
these guys are basically swapping places
yeah 1 minus cos 2x happy with that so
this is not too dramatic can someone
tell me what the primitive function is
going to do is to okay just momentarily
check once you've read your content that
that does check out differentiating your
head is it going to work out yeah
because the inside derivative is going
to cancel with the half sine turns into
normal cosine of the signs are preserved
also- is preserved looks good ok so
another first example a savings in
abroad is to say well what happens if
instead of this guy by himself what if I
have something like this
what differences are meant to have that
person there yeah we use Association
okay I'm going to think about
substitution okay now again as an
extension one student series before now
becoming more familiar this is another
form f dash and this is f of x squared
do you see that sign X or square so if I
want to make it really clear in my mind
I mean there's no boundary values to
worry about so I could say over here let
u equal what substitutions I've been
doing just regular sine X so therefore
do you call them DX is equal to do it
comes okay so because I've chosen a nice
simple example it's all there sitting
there for you something mighty come to
turn it down yeah the Cossacks I'm just
going to do a straight substitution for
D or D X right like so that's not sign
exit sign x or squared so this is going
to become when i substitute it u squared
and then I've got my DX still hanging
there right so cancel cancel this is a
very simple one so what is to come plus
my constant and then I just need to
climb back and undo my substitution
okay now these you've seen before okay
I'm now going to push further into
extension to live which is that like you
guys pretty much immediately jumped it's
cuz you recognize it ok you can see as
well if I had something like don't write
this down if I had something like this
even though it's a bit like course okay
this is not that difficult to deal with
right what would I do in this case what
could I do yeah I'm kind of just going
to have to do it twice right like this
is going to be take breath this is going
to be a half 1 minus cos 2x that's sine
squared what I just wrote down and then
you just square it again okay so then
you're gonna have another close square
deal with that but that's okay any even
number of powers if I ever bet I've got
six that's what you're gonna have to
think of these guys okay in principle I
can deal with the question just gets the
long guy doesn't need any new skills
right okay but what it example
what if the power is not something nice
and neat this is not what I wanted but
it is not what I wanted so how am I
going to deal with something like this
okay yeah get split it into sine x times
sine square okay so this doesn't get us
out of the woods I will point out if you
have a look at this right okay I can
deal with this part I've got some tools
here but how do i do with the other part
how I deal with it in summary I wouldn't
need both of these pieces together I'm
going to portrait event let's see if you
can get a bit of a head start on me how
are you going to work with this enough
of you show me I know some people still
working but we can remove case together
what substitution am I going to make
what identity will I use i'm going to
use wherever if i had it really yeah
like this side square here i'm kind of
going to use the Pythagorean II that's
sort of behind here that I used in at
that point there so i'm going to write
this as sine x times 1 minus cos we're
okay now why is this more useful they're
like I showed you I showed you this
stops issue before but this is going to
give you excuse me this is going to give
you a dead end right I want to avoid
this why what problem is just going to
leave me with yeah that cos 2x is a
problem right the cos 2x an issue
because it's x sine X sine X is not the
derivative of quantity x is it I don't
want to use that I'm going to stay with
just single axis which is why use the
ruler
so what happens here I'm entering now
sine X take away sine X cos squared X
but this looks just like my second
attempt because it not it's slightly sit
around ok so I'm going to integrate what
am I going to get from side x negative
context now we're getting to this point
we're doing you to do this substitution
on the side can I do this in my head if
I had cos squared X it must have come
from its cause cubed x right so if i had
a cause huge x here what would happen if
I differentiated caused a huge x ok so
what happen is I would do the dude on
the inside which will become minus sign
that's perfect that's what I want but
then how to do the outside so what would
happen in this this three would become a
3 out to find you and I don't have in
through here so how do i compensate yeah
i'm going to divide by 3 right so this 3
that comes out in front will cancel
leaving me with a coefficient of 1 how
about the sign the puzzle of minors I
want the plus don't I ok because
remember that inside derivative was
minus sign which is exactly what i
already have thing and then my constant
does that make sense yeah did you get
did you end up this is what well
somewhere else I did like that i use the
1 minus cos 2 theta 2 equal sign is
quite real and then in order to get
signed I just we're really got identity
so you had this is a half 1 minus 1
minus close to zero yeah I mean when I'm
to find the sign I basically times got
five square root of the second identity
what because I'm excited how did you get
to hurt them because they're what you
lose you can
take like one on two out and one on
route 2 out and then you've got 1 minus
cos 30 times square root one point oh ok
I see what you've got yeah oh then you
get three on Two and then you can go 5-1
yeah okay yeah there are some problems
with okay you got through this number
one it's going to get ugly very long
you've probably seen oh it's become a
bit this young secondly by having to
introduce these guys we see before in
the new center one context like no one I
don't want to see if I can avoid it
right and I clearly cares like this is
true for all values of x I don't have to
worry about positive when they gives or
have you something this is clearly a
better part I just leave yeah that's
okay ya know